okay so I'm just gonna say this I want
to make more videos and specifically I
want to make more map videos I've been
doing this thing lately where I take
paper maps like like this I have loads
of them paper maps everywhere in my life
I mean look at this beauty of Mexico
paper maps been doing this thing where
I'd take paper maps and then I scan them
and then I geo rectify them to a digital
map and then I do a bunch of other stuff
and before you know it I'm actually
animating that map with the mountains
and all this stuff
you've probably seen it in some of these
videos this is a workflow I've been
working on for years and I love it and
helps me tell stories in a new way using
original maps but the problem is with
this all of this takes a lot of time a
lot of effort it's just a lot of hours
of dinking around on my computer trying
to make this look good writing scripts
doing all of that so one solution to
this is I want to start a patreon to see
if all of you are interested in helping
support me make these kind of in-depth
time intensive videos right now I've
been making a series called how the u.s.
stole fill-in-the-blank I did how the
u.s. stolen Island Diego Garcia how the
u.s. stole Hawaii and I've got a lot
more turns out the u.s. stole a lot of
stuff these videos are really time
intensive I do reporting I call experts
I do loads of animation just a lot of
writing fact-checking
it's just a lot but I want to keep
making them and I think people like them
and having a patreon would allow me to
do that with more time and to not be so
dependent on scrambling for the next
brand deal or whatever it is to help
support me while I make stuff keeping up
super high quality visuals and
journalism and storytelling is my
priority and that just takes time and
effort so anyway that's what I'm doing
starting to patreon okay you know the
drill with patreon you give a few bucks
and you help support me and I also give
you some cool benefits like some behind
the scenes stuff and whatever I'm not
going to try to convince you on why you
should support me
patreon if it's a question or if it's a
stretch I don't want anyone to even get
close to stretching themselves
financially to support this so that's
just let's just get that out of the way
but let me tell you about a few benefits
that may be useful to some of you the
first here we'll get a high-res
screenshot from a video so I will design
up a either a map or some scene from the
video and deliver a high-res desktop
background so you'll be able to put this
on your computer and look at beautiful
maps and change it up once a month
because I'll deliver a new one every
month or so for a few more bucks
the next here gets access to all my
scripts so I write everything in detail
with all my visual direction it's all
color-coded and fancy and that is a
little bit of like looking under the
hood of how these videos are made so it
might be useful if you want to see how I
build these scripts and build these
videos the next here is a director's
commentary so I'll take a video that I
did that month and I will do a
director's commentary where I watch it
through and I tell you about all the
other stuff that didn't make it into the
video I'll tell you about the processes
of what I was thinking when I made this
map and oh the extra side story that
went along with this thing and all the
stuff that like I can't fit into like a
ten minute video and trust me there's
loads of it I mean there's so much more
stuff that goes into these videos that
just doesn't make it in and this
director's commentary will be me
talking through and unpacking all of the
side stories and extra information from
a video that month finally the top tier
is a full-on behind the scenes of some
process that I've done that month so
what I'll do is I'll turn on my screen
recording and I will talk through
probably an animation it's probably
gonna be mostly animation and maps how I
design things how I little techniques
that I'm using how I'm using the camera
how I do all of these techniques I get a
lot of questions about how things are
done especially my map workflow and this
top tier will be getting once a month a
little behind the scenes tidbit of how
I'm making something it'll be like a
screen recording of After Effects this
isn't a full-on tutorial I'm not gonna
like unpack start to finish how to do a
workflow but I will be giving you a
little glimpse
- how the sausage is made no sausage
being made actually sounds pretty gross
it's not gross it's just like
after-effects which kind of to some
people looks like sausage move so that
behind-the-scenes screen recording is
for the top tier if you're interested
and you want to learn that might be
worth it to you that's patreon those are
the little tiers that I'll be doing and
of course it maybe goes without saying
but any tier you go up you get all of
the benefits of the lower tiers in
addition to that tier as well I think
that's probably like common knowledge
but maybe it's not I don't know so
that's it that's patreon the links in
the description if you want to go check
it out patreon.com slash Johnny Harris
and all the info will be there I'm
really excited about this about having
more room to make longer more ambitious
videos and I hope you will support but
again if you're not like in a place to
support don't support like let's just be
responsible with your money please but
if you do want to support the creation
of these in-depth ambitious videos I
would love to have you along for the
ride thank you all for supporting this
channel it's crazy to watch it grow into
and to be able to make stuff and see
what people are interested in and I'm
just gonna keep on truckin so I'll see
you on the other side
you